it's me Johnny mnemonic William Gibson's
data carrying courier from the Year 2021
could store in dozens of gigabytes of
data in his head we still haven't
figured out how to upload files directly
to our brains the bio hackers are
finding new ways to use technology to
change human bodies and push the limits
of what's possible from implants that
extend our vision the chips that let us
open doors a device called pegleg is a
new frontier of privacy storing and
transferring data in the human body but
only if you can stomach a 30-minute
operation we spoke with Michael offer at
the bio hacker and one of the creators
of this new device what do you have in
your leg I have a half terabyte pirate
server it's open access so where did the
idea from this come when the internet
first started when I was a little kid
there was so much promise we all hoped
that and we believed we didn't just hope
but we believed that it was going to be
this thing that set us all free and it
was going to fix so many things because
it was going to be impossible and
manipulate impossible the sensor
impossible to surveil as we've seen all
of those things have turned out to be
false we see that surveillance is
happening just about everywhere from
just about everywhere they can afford it
now can you tell me a little bit about
what the pegleg is and how it works the
basis for it is a Raspberry Pi 0w so it
has Wi-Fi built-in there's a an antenna
built into the PCB here is where you
have your microSD card that holds the
software and is also the data repository
this one is just 16 gigs mine's 512 this
unit here is a second Wi-Fi card this
allows for it to communicate to other
peg legs
that's the mesh part of the network on
the back we have the coil that allows it
to accept power this is the power
management circuitry and then this is a
capacitor that acts as a power buffer
that allows fluctuations in
and put when you hold a battery to
pegleg it creates the network that
anyone who has a Internet enabled device
can then connect to right so it's like a
Wi-Fi hotspot in that way whatever you
have you just look for a Wi-Fi networks
and pegleg will come up and you click on
it and then the splash screen cut it's
not connected to the regular Internet
right right when we have a local area
network then all of us in this room can
connect to it we can talk but nobody's
gonna be able to surveil that unless
they're here and again everything's
anonymous so how would you know who's
saying what anyway so go ahead and turn
your Wi-Fi on and then in your list of
networks you should see an open network
that says pegleg and select that I'm in
and then if you go down it should say
browse files ok and these are all the
files stored on your leg yeah so far I
know there aren't many but the one that
says Omni is the issue of Omni from 1981
where Johnny mnemonic first appeared
downloads pretty fast my speed internet
a high speed anti Internet pegleg as far
as implants go is pretty large can you
tell me a little bit about what the
procedure was like getting this in your
leg I've never had surgery of any kind
so it was new for me it was it was a new
thing but everybody was there and they
were very supportive I was told that I
did faint for a few seconds it was less
than 30 minutes
he made an incision and then made a
pocket and slid the thing up and sutured
it up this device that you now I've
gotten implanted in your body is already
existed as a piece of physical hardware
that provided this capability I would
say everybody so what are the advantages
of putting it in your leg ah right this
is always the key question this is
different because a wearable can be
confiscated in a border and a wearable
has to have an internal power source
that will fail and wearables don't talk
to each other part of the magic
of it is that they can't compel me to
turn it on I mean I suppose they could
strap me to a chair and put a battery up
to it if they understood it well enough
to do that but it's a passive device it
only turns on if I wanted to it doesn't
even matter because it's an open network
anyway so anything that I would want to
shroud would be encrypted and it
wouldn't matter who are these community
of people getting these devices them the
grinding community is sort of a sub-sub
culture within the biohacking subculture
the grinders are ones who are fearlessly
innovative the bleeding edge as it were
and so there's been a lot of really
fascinating experiments that have come
out of the grinding community I'm sure
you've seen some of them like the
night-vision eye drops and the flexible
armor implants these people are saying
look it's my body and I have autonomy
over it I can do what I want and I'm not
afraid because I think this could make
the world better
hmm then they do most biohackers that
I've ever met are very aware that what
they're doing is dangerous you
understand to some degree what you're
doing I mean to be fair right you're
taking risk every time you take a
medicine every time you go for surgery
in a hospital the the differentiation is
that in the United States especially but
in the Western world we have a terrible
habit of outsourcing responsibility I
think about how many people you know who
only even changed their own oil or fix
their own computer or void the warranty
on anything they own it's really
exciting to me to realize that because
of the pace which the grinders are
taking biohacking
the next big innovation to come out of
biology it's equally likely to come out
of somebody's garage than it is to come
out of an Ivy League Research Institute
you arguably best known within the
biohacking community for your role as
the public face of for thieves
your collective can you tell me a little
bit about what that project is for
thieves is a collective that works to
try to bring medicine and medical
technology to people who don't have it
what we've done over the years is worked
on projects that allow people to again
manage their own health ways to
manufacture their own medicines or build
their own medical technologies so that
they can bypass all those problems if
what they need is too expensive or not
legal where they are or just not
available where they are then they can
take control their own health and still
have access to the technology which
exists people should be able to
interface with the medical community and
be able to have more open conversations
with their medical providers and be able
to audit the systems that they're
putting into their bodies and be able to
look at the pharmaceuticals and and read
all the studies that we're done couldn't
someone presumably take the instructions
that you're providing and mix something
incorrectly and even though they're
doing it themselves if they don't have a
background in chemistry if I get
something from an institution it's an
act of faith that that institution has
the safety protocols that I would deem
appropriate and I don't get to see those
or check those if I'm at home and I
manufacture a pill I know everything
that went into it I made the pill one at
a time I know how much I had to
pharmaceutical ingredient went into this
pill and I closed it I capped it I took
it I'm safe for thieves hasn't released
any data so it's impossible to know how
many people are using this or if it's
been effective but Laufer says he and
other bio hackers continue to dream up
new ways of using technology to augment
their own capability bio hacking has
always figured prominently in science
fiction William Gibson he made prolific
use of body modifications and his
stories and does that influenced the way
you think about body hacking when I when
I put this in I had a
where I thought the only thing better
than witnessing your childhood dreams
coming true is making them come true and
it was a great moment to sort of see
joining them on it come to life Michael
thank you so much for joining us and
telling us about the future of the
Internet which is inside your leg well I
hope so and a lot of other places thanks
so much yeah thanks